Is there a downside to eating late at night,
besides getting crumbs in your bed?
Hey there science cravers, Julian here for
DNews.
A lot of diet fads are very specific about
what you should eat, but hardly any of them
talk about when you should eat.
That’s because for years now the conventional
wisdom has basically been that the overall
number of calories you eat vs how many you
burn is what’s important.
But a few studies have challenged this idea.
One in 2013 published in the International
Journal of Obesity followed 420 obese or overweight
adults who were trying to lose weight over
20 weeks.
Those who ate their largest meal before 3PM
on average lost almost 2 kg more than those
who ate after, even if caloric intake and
amount of exercise was the same.
But why should that be the case?
It’s possible the same calorie may be treated
differently depending on where your body is
in it’s circadian rhythm.
Yes the 24 hour cycle that we usually just
associate with our sleep schedule also has
an effect on how our bodies absorb and digest
food.
So eating out of our normal rhythm can contribute
to weight gain according to Kelly Allison
of the University of Pennsylvania School of
Medicine’s Center for Weight and Eating
Disorders.
Wow that is one bloated title.
So what’s causing us to eat out of our regular
rhythms?
Society, man.
The way we work has caused a sort of social
jet lag, where the time we have available
to eat doesn’t match the time it would be
most ideal to eat.
We’re skipping breakfast more, and our meal
times are becoming irregular as we focus on
getting work done or picking up the kids from
school.
We may actually be intentionally fighting
the circadian rhythm, when it causes cortisol
and adrenaline to drop off around 3 PM.
To stave off the sleepiness some of us indulge
in something high in sugar or fat.
According to Pamela Peeke, an assistant professor
at the University of Maryland School of Medicine,
this will raise our insulin levels and we’ll
crave sugar later.
Our circadian rhythm is at odds with our modern
lifestyle in other ways too.
When we first evolved food wasn’t readily
available in refrigerators when we woke up.
So it’s possible that as the day progresses,
the food we eat is more apt to turn into fat
so the next day we have a convenient reserve
of energy and don’t have to worry about
our first meal.
That’s the hypothesis of Steven Shea, director
of the Oregon Institute of Occupational Health
Sciences.
Shea also noticed in his research that people
tend to be hungrier later at night, possibly
as part of this evolutionary adaptation.
Combine that with the fact that since artificial
light we stay up later than ever and now have
ready access to food, and the result is some
people can’t resist a late night bite.
Furthermore, if you are grabbing food late
at night, you’re more likely to make an
unhealthy choice.
You might do it out of convenience, because
it’s easier to grab a bag of chips than
make a salad, or you might do it out of mental
exhaustion.
If you’ve spent the whole day on your best
dietary behavior, late at night you’re more
willing to let yourself slip, or even reward
yourself with something fatty, salty, sweet,
and delicious.
Even the researchers who study this admit
that chrononutrition is an underexplored topic,
with few studies done so far and many of them
relying on mice.
While the studies we’ve cited point to a
link between late day eating and weight gain,
plenty of others support the orthodox view
that net calorie count is the most important
factor.
Once again more research is needed.
I hope it involves cake.
If you love food science and food in general
click here now to check out our friends over
at eater.
Have
you tried shifting your caloric intake to
earlier in the day?
How did that work out for you?